are you a good girl
[Music]
you're a dirty little girl
who's in charge here what the hell do
you want at my crime scene or the fbi
i'm with the state police give me a
shout i'm supposed to be protecting
these girls
it's not your operation you
belong to me you understand what i'm
saying now lift up that skirt
no
the minute i got made bait it became my
operation
i have communication with over a dozen
active offenders
we had a bonafide serial killer
i kind of think i was looking for you
i got a girl with a skull cracked in six
places
the bite marks it matches me
another girl vanished from a truck stop
outside pensacola last night
stop it there who's that
get up it's purification time
who was he trying to cuff one of my
girls he had a lightning bolt on his
truck
he's hurting some girl right now
i can set him up again
you sure do look familiar
not never get such a pretty face
cheers promised me this is gonna be
bad hello somebody there do everything
that you can to get out
where is she
folks now you live alone i just want to
keep an eye out for you
[Music]
you're going to get me killed we'll have
a little party
don't you worry we'll have our time
[Music]
together